Yassine Moyo was just 13 years old his
family say he was shot dead by police on
Monday evening they were enforcing a
curfew here in Kenya's capital Nairobi
the problem is the government his uncle
told us he was at home on his balcony
with other children when a bullet hit
him in the stomach the curfew does not
mean to shoot people even he was adopted
by that time he supposed to be caught I
rested my taking with the police not
routine as we know even if it's a you
know even it's a TV where W shoot
someone who is in his house the
government brought in restrictions to
try and slow the spread of kovat 19 the
curfew killed Yasin before the virus
Yasin has been laid to rest his family
say they want justice and they're not
the only ones who aren't happy with
Kenya's curfew in the port city of
Mombasa police used tear gas to break up
crowds before the curfew began rights
groups play pleased and making things
worse we believe that the curfew is
necessary in order to flatten the curve
but we don't necessarily think that we
do not believe that flattening people at
the same time actually helps the fight
against Kovach 19 to be really frank we
see more deaths at the moment from
violent policing than we've seen from
korvac 19 in the western city of
Kissimmee police also fired tear gas to
close a market enforcing another one of
the new restrictions the people depend
on markets for income and food
restrictions are making life harder and
as the virus spreads people expecting a
greater lockdown in the weeks ahead the
president has made a rare apology for
police brutality police say some of its
officers are being held to account and
the police chief has ordered an
investigation into yeah Singh's death
his family say they'll welcome justice
but it won't bring him back
Malcolm Webb al Jazeera Nairobi Kenya